revisar sus registros personales en
busca de documentos presidenciales Esto
es lo que pidió la oficina de archivos
nacionales en una carta enviada a los
expresidentes y ex vicepresidentes desde
la administración de Ronald Reagan hasta
la de Donald Trump la responsabilidad de
cumplir con la ley de registros
presidenciales no disminuye tras el
final de un gobierno por lo tanto
solicitamos que lleve a cabo una
evaluación de cualquier material
conservado fuera de los archivos
nacionales y administración de
documentos la solicitud se presenta solo
días después de que los abogados del ex
vicepresidente Mike pence se informaran
del hallazgo de documentos en su
residencia de Indiana asegurando que
habrían llegado ahí por error
el exfuncionario se sumó así al
escándalo de documentos clasificados en
el que también está envuelto el
presidente Joe biden con hallazgos en su
residencia de Wilmington en enero y en
su oficina privada en el pent biden
Center en noviembre pasado en estos dos
casos los archivos fueron encontrados
por abogados que notificaron a las
autoridades y los entregaron contrario
al caso del expresidente Donald Trump en
el que los documentos fueron encontrados
en medio de un allanamiento en su casa
de mar halago en Florida
la preocupación es que alguien pueda
acceder a ellos poniendo nuestros
secretos en riesgo la información
clasificada contiene material que debe
ser protegido por seguridad nacional
la solicitud de los archivos nacionales
incluye revisar tanto documentos
clasificados como no clasificados y
aplica las administraciones posteriores
a la de Jimmy Carter que fue el
signatario de la ley de registros
presidenciales la normativa Establece
que todos los registros presidenciales
se transfieren a la custodia de los
archivos nacionales en cuanto el
presidente deja el cargo